Thôi đồng thamu trường liên quân Mỹ Jane Kane, nghe mục bà tham một truyết,
quả chính trình Mỹ cho chính sịch đột tích và với đu dừa ra,
bất đầu tư tháng 6,5 in không trong làm khi các quang tình báo tăng cường theo sỏi
chặt trẻ lịch chính và nơi ờ của tổng thống với đu dừa ra,
đi của la Smado Ro, một nhóm điệp viên CIA đã đi mật sâm nhật
thật khá s, thú thập thông tin cho kịch bản bắt sử và sức tắn hua tiêu.
Sấm sòng vừa đau của đổi Mỹ đã tiến hành yếu được lệnh tập với môi mô phạm
của sinh thượng của tổng thống Maduro, các khi tài như mấy bài chính sát,
ua, vui, và hải quân cũng được chình khai dần từ Caribeh trong những tháng
của năm nay, những không trong làm theo Washington thời điểm hành động được lựa
trọng ký lưỡng để tận dụng sự bất ngờ.
Tổng thống Mỹ đưa nên trăm cho biết đã phí dưới chính sịch và tổng thay tháng
một chào quên trên khai của thế cho lâu năm thấp.
Về phía vinh率 dưa ra chính quên khá lơ khác cảnh đình.
Chỉnh sịch vý phạm nghiêm trọng chủ quyền của gia và yếu cầu lập tức trọng trả
thống như nhẹ Maduro của mình vào phần yếu sống của tấn công,
hàng loại khu giả khác và tổng thương kỳ lên của ông Anh Chua Nil Kirtress đã lên tiếng
cảnh máu khu không cách và bác sử vý phạm lột phó cuối tế,
tạo ra tìm lệ nguy hiệm và đeïs hoạ tế hoạ bình Anh Anh khu vực.